-The President's path
to re-election is narrowing
as the remaining swing states
continue counting ballots.
So now his team is trying
a new strategy --
keep counting Trump votes,
but stop counting Biden votes.
For more on this, it's time
for "A Closer Look."
♪♪
It's worth noting that we tape
our show at 5:00 P.M.
so we don't know if there's
going to be
a call tonight or not.
But things are looking pretty
good for Joe Biden.
But Donald Trump, political
mastermind that he is,
has discovered a hack.
Just declare the states
you want to win
and claim victory
without evidence.
-He said, quote,
"We have claimed
for electoral vote purposes
the Commonwealth
of Pennsylvania,
which won't allow
legal observers,
the state of Georgia, and the
state of North Carolina,
each one of which has
a big Trump lead.
Additionally, we hereby claim
the state of Michigan
if, in fact,
there was a large number
of secretly dumped ballots as
has been widely reported."
-I love when Trump tries to
write something in legalese
and ends up sounding like
Bill and Ted arguing over
who gets shotgun in a car.
"I hereby claim the front seat
for the ride to White Castle."
"Ah, but as you can see, my hand
has heretofore been placed
upon the exterior of
the vehicle,
therefore negating your verbal
declaration of shotgun,
and thus, your claim must be
withdrawn forthwith."
Also, I love that Trump
thinks using the word "hereby"
makes his tweet an official
legal document.
The guy's spent most of his life
in court,
and that's the only
thing he learned.
[ As Trump ] "If anyone's
giving you trouble,
just throw in a 'hereby.'
nobody comes back from that."
And it wasn't just Trump.
Everyone in and around
his campaign, from his weird
adult sons,
to his campaign manager,
tried to just claim victory
in Pennsylvania without
any evidence
before the votes
had been counted.
-White House Spokesperson
Kayleigh McEnany tweeted,
"Victory for President
in Pennsylvania."
-We've declared victory
in Pennsylvania.
-We are declaring a victory
-Oh, you're declaring
victory in Pennsylvania?
Okay.
Well, I'm declaring myself
King of the Andals
and the First Men,
Lord of the Seven Kingdoms,
and Protector of the Realm
and my first official act is
not sending that dragon
to fight the Night King.
Also, can someone tell me again
how Bran got elected?
Did Westeros also have
an electoral college?
Were there a lot of Bran fans
in Maricopa County?
"And again, you have to
remember, we expect Maricopa
to break late for Bran."
Anyway, the point is, you don't
just get to declare victory
in any state, and no one cares
that you did.
I mean, I guess we have to care
a little bit
because you're the President,
and you wield
an insane amount of power.
But ideally, you know, we'd just
ignore you.
When someone gets on the subway
and declares themself
king of the F Train
and demands tribute,
you don't stand up and start
arguing with them, saying,
"Actually, according
to MTA bylaws,
none of the trains
have monarchs."
You just turn up the volume
on your AirPods.
No one's buying these false
declarations of victory,
in part because even
the Trump team
can't keep their bull [bleep]
straight.
In Pennsylvania, they want to
stop the count
while they're ahead.
In Arizona, however,
they're suddenly concerned
that the counting will stop
while they're behind.
If you thought Trump ghouls
have plumbed the depths
of their shamelessness,
think again,
because here's Kellyanne Conway
and Sarah Huckabee Sanders
on Fox News this morning
claiming that
when it comes to states
Trump is losing,
we should take our time,
after months of insisting
ballots should not be counted
after election day.
-Arizona and Pennsylvania,
I think, are key
for the President.
And those are both places where
he still has a path to victory.
And so I think it is incredibly
too early
for them to make that
type of announcement,
because we've still got votes
left to be counted
and I think that has to be
completed before we can
determine who the winner is.
-We spent three years --
they spent three years
investigating the President,
impeaching the President.
We can't wait three hours,
three days, three weeks
to get a result in our great
sturdy democracy
as to whom the next
President will be?
I mean, what is the rush?
-Yeah, what's the rush?
Let's take our time!
Three hours, three days,
three weeks, three years!
Let's take our time
to figure this out,
because if Donald Trump is known
for one thing,
it's patience.
Trump is the least patient
man alive.
You can tell because even
when he's standing still,
he sways back and forth
like a fourth grader
posing for a school photo.
"I mean, is your bladder full?
Is you have to go, go."
We're going to find out years
later that Trump held it in
the whole time
he was in office.
"I can only go in my gold toilet
at home."
That's right. After months
of claiming any delay
in counting would be suspicious,
and they wanted all
the votes counted and declared
on election night, now they want
us all to take our time
and make sure every vote
is counted, which is correct.
We agree.
Count every vote, everywhere.
In reality, of course, they'll
just switch to whatever position
suits their political interest.
Next, they're gonna argue we
should wait four years to count
and let Trump crash with Joe at
the White House in the meantime.
"We're out of toilet paper,
Joe."
[ As Biden ] "It's noon.
What are you doing out here
in your bath robe?"
"I was watching Fox News.
They think you stink."
"I'm trying to work here."
"Yeah, I had this job.
It's the worst."
You almost got to applaud their
ability to pivot on a dime
from one brazen lie to another
contradictory lie.
But hey, you heard it.
The President's closest and most
trusted advisers,
let's take our time
and count all the votes,
and we agree --
count every vote,
in every state, everywhere.
I am so glad that's settled.
[ Typing ]
Oh. Oh my God. That's weird.
Okay, I hear typing.
Almost as if someone is angrily
tweeting, misspelling it,
and then tweeting it again.
-President Trump there
tweeted, "Stop the count."
-Oh, no! But what about
Kellyanne Conway's credibility?
How will we ever believe
anything she says ever again?
That tweet came like an hour
after Conway and the other Trump
hacks were all over Fox News
claiming that actually
we need to keep
counting all the ballots.
Trying to stay on message
with Trump is like
trying to ride a mechanical bull
slathered in olive oil.
And then again, today, Trump
tried to use his magical powers
of tweeting to declare, without
any basis in law whatsoever,
that ballots postmarked by
election day,
but received after election day
should not be counted.
And once again, as they've done
with many of his
deranged tweets,
Twitter censored it
because it was a lie.
-Mail-in ballot counting
continues in Philadelphia,
despite President Trump's tweet
saying, "Any vote that came in
after election day
will not be counted."
-Sorry, bud,
that's not up to you.
That's like me saying, "Any
writer who leaves before 5:00
will not be paid."
I mean, they all do it anyway.
At least the ones who are sober
enough to make it to the subway.
True story, my writers
don't even know
we do interviews on this show.
But I have to say,
it will be fun to see
if Trump keeps trying
his magic Twitter powers
after he leaves office.
"Any guac added at Chipotle
will be free of charge!"
There are many states,
including swing states,
where as long as
your ballot is postmarked
on or before the election,
it can be counted afterward.
Those states include
Pennsylvania and North Carolina,
but there are also a bunch
of heavily Republican states
that do the same thing, like
Mississippi, North Dakota,
Iowa, Texas, Ohio,
West Virginia,
Utah, and Alaska.
Of course, in Alaska they have
to give you extra time,
because the mail there is
delivered via malamute.
And this is a real tangent,
but all day long I've read
that line and thought
it should be a lyric
in a Beastie Boys song.
♪ I get all my mail
delivered by a malamute ♪
Also, I gotta say that it's so
great Trump is spending
the days after the election
with basically
his entire Twitter feed
censored.
It's like taking away
Zorro's sword.
Without it, he's just
a creepy dude
with a mustache
and a cape.
"Yeah, Officer, I'd like to
report a weird man
who just fogged up my window
and drew a 'Z' with his finger."
I wish we could slap the Twitter
warning label
on Trump's mouth
whenever he talks.
[ No Audio ]
To be clear, there's no
evidence for fraud anywhere.
The best they can come up with
is a dumb and obviously fake
Internet rumor claiming Arizona
officials duped Trump voters
into filling out ballots
with Sharpie,
knowing that Sharpie would be
disqualified, which it's not.
"Allies of President Trump
are promoting a baseless
conspiracy theory that poll
workers tricked Trump voters
by providing them with Sharpies
to cast their votes
and then rejected the ballots
due to the use of the marker."
It must be so hard for the Trump
administration to pretend
to be anti-Sharpie.
It's what he used to white his
inauguration speech.
It's also what he uses to sign
boobs and control the weather.
I'm pretty sure it's what
Rudy uses to get hyped up
for his Fox appearances.
Second, my favorite thing about
this is even their best attempt
at claiming fraud involves
admitting that they're
easily tricked doofuses.
What happened?
Did a guy in a white van pull up
and say, "Hey, you going to vote
for President?
You wanna do it with a Sharpie?
Ooh, you using a pen, square?"
There's no evidence of fraud
in Pennsylvania either,
where they're literally just
counting the ballots
that have been legitimately
cast, as they always do.
And you can tell even the Trump
team is struggling to keep up
this line of BS because
they're getting challenged
on their favorite TV channel,
Fox News,
as White House Press Secretary
Kayleigh McEnany
discovered on Wednesday.
-We have election days in this
country for a reason.
It's because votes are counted
on election day.
So we are fighting for the
American people to know
sooner rather than later.
We want the votes to be counted.
-But Kayleigh, we always
have had provisional ballots
and military ballots
that get counted later.
The votes have to be in
by November 3rd,
that was what their
state legislature
and their court system --
-Postmarked.
-...agreed to,
that it had to be
postmarked by November 3rd
and then counted.
So the voting is happening
on election day.
-And the legislature, you're
right, determines the time,
the manner and the place
in which an election happens.
We believe every vote on
election day should be counted.
But it's those that arrive after
the election day
that we are fighting in court.
-Even if they already voted
on November 3rd,
which is the postmark?
-We are fighting for those
that are after November 3rd.
We want election day ballots
to be counted.
-♪ Yeah, and I got more lies
than Kayleigh McEnany ♪
[ Laughter ]
First of all, I love
how her only move is
to just keep nodding her head,
even while she's being
fact checked,
as if the anchors
disproving her lies
are actually agreeing
with her.
It's like watching a drunk
person argue with a cop.
"Ma'am, did you know you were
swerving between lanes?"
"Yes, yes, Officer,
I was changing lanes."
"You almost hit a tree, ma'am."
"Yes. Yeah, I was trying to
park in the woods."
The Trump campaign is desperate
to manufacture
some non-existent fraud in order
to steal the election,
so they sent their best man
to Philadelphia,
the Italian Ziggy,
Rudy Giuliani.
Rudy held a press conference
in Philadelphia yesterday
where he claimed,
with zero evidence,
there was fraud happening,
and that Democrats were somehow
stealing the election by, again,
just counting the votes.
-How many votes
do we have to be ahead?
400,000's not enough?
With 80-plus percent counted?
I think there's only 14%
of the vote to go.
Do you think we're stupid?
Do you think we're fools?
-Uh, yeah.
Hard yes on both counts.
It's like when a metal band
takes the stage
and asks if
you're ready to rock.
You don't really have to ask.
I wouldn't have bought
Megadeth tickets
if I was looking for a quiet
night of reflection, man.
No offense, Rudy, but I don't
trust you to tell us
who's up and who's down,
since you don't know
the difference between
up and down.
-From the top to the bottom,
from the middle to the side.
-Can you imagine
how confusing it must be
when he reports back to Trump?
"Great news, Donald, you're up
here, while Biden's down here.
Now if you need me, I'll be
in the middle."
Seriously, Rudy, it might be
time to pack it in.
Or, in your case, tuck it in.
Man, every time Rudy sees
that clip, he must think,
[ As Borat ]
"[Bleep] my life!"
[ Laughter ]
That was for Shoemaker.
You know the funny thing
about Shoemaker,
he doesn't like Borat,
he just likes when
people do the impression.
[ Laughter ]
Again, Rudy just made up
a bunch of lies
without any evidence at all.
He claimed mail-in ballots,
which we've been counting
since the Civil War,
were a new thing
and somehow fraudulent,
that voters were being bussed in
from other states,
that Joe Biden himself
somehow voted 50 times,
and even that dead people
might be voting.
-This whole new thing that never
happened before
in our country,
these mail-in ballots,
which has been a cause of real
concern for everyone,
because they can easily
be fraudulent.
And you have a reputation
of people being bussed in
from Camden voting here.
Wouldn't be the first time
that happened.
Joe Biden could have voted
50 times as far as we know,
or 5,000 times.
Philadelphia, unfortunately,
and I would say this
about my own city, has
a reputation for voter fraud.
You have a reputation
for dead people voting.
And we're gonna go look at just
how many dead people voted here.
-Of course Rudy thinks
dead people voted. He voted.
"We have proof that
dead people are voting.
I just went to a polling place
yesterday, and they let me in,
even after I blew a zero
on the thermometer.
And we need voter I.D. laws,
nobody even checked my toe tag."
How are you gonna look at
how many dead people voted?
Are you gonna go to the morgue
and see if any of the corpses
are wearing stickers?
"Boss, I found another one."
All of this is so dumb
and transparent,
but unfortunately,
it has consequences.
Trump supporters
believe this stuff,
which is why one of them
crashed a press conference
in Nevada yesterday screaming
that Joe Biden
was stealing the election.
-As I mentioned,
we are not prepared
to give that number now.
-The Biden crime family is
stealing the election!
The media is covering up!
The Biden crime family is
stealing this election!
The media is covering it up!
The Biden crime family's
stealing this election!
The media's covering it up.
We want our freedom
for the world!
Give us our freedom, Joe Biden!
Biden's covering up this
election, he's stealing it!
[ Camera shutters click ]
-Where were we?
What was the last question?
-I mean, that's fantastic
how he finishes screaming
and just walks away like a guy
complaining about his order
at the deli.
"I said, 'No mustard!'
no mustard!'"
[ Laughter ]
It's so hard to take your claims
of voter fraud seriously
when you're wearing a tank top
that looks like you won it
in a wing-eating contest.
You're not allowed to make
legal claims
when you're not
wearing sleeves.
"And can we assume you're
from the law firm
of Barbecue, Beer,
and Freedom?"
"Oh, it's actually Barbecue,
Beer, Freedom, and Leibowitz."
I mean, look at your outfit.
You look like Mike Scollins
in a Zoom meeting.
[ Laughter ]
That joke made my
writing staff very happy.
Well, almost all of them.
So Trump, Kellyanne Conway,
Sarah Huckabee Sanders,
Kayleigh McEnany, Rudy Giuliani,
none of them keep
their stories straight,
which is why even the crowds
of Trump supporters
harassing and intimidating
poll workers
can't keep their stories
straight either.
In Michigan, where Trump
started out ahead,
they called on poll workers
to stop counting votes.
But in Arizona, where Trump
is behind,
they called for the opposite.
-Truly, we are
a nation divided.
I don't think Trump voters
actually know
what they're chanting.
I just think they love to chant.
"Build that wall."
"Lock 'em up."
"Count the votes."
"Stop the count."
It doesn't actually matter, they
just love three-word phrases.
If we could just send in the
Barbecue, Beer, and Freedom guy
and have him do a keg stand,
they'd quickly switch
to chanting, "Drink that beer!
Drink that beer!"
Personally, I think
the best chance we have
for distracting
these Trump supporters
and keeping them away from poll
workers is to just sic them
on each other and let them
shout back and forth.
-Stop the count.
-Count those votes.
-Count the votes.
-Stop the count.
-Count those votes.
-And then we can just
leave them there
to yell at each other
for four years
while the rest of us
get on with our lives.
This is a dangerous moment.
The President and his supporters
telegraphed for weeks
that they would try
to steal the election,
and now they're doing it.
We can't let them.
We have to count every ballot,
in every state, everywhere...
-From the top to the bottom,
from the middle to the side.
-This has been "A Closer Look."
♪♪
God's Love We Deliver
cooks and brings
over 2 million meals a year
to men, women, and children
living with HIV/AIDS, cancer,
and other serious illnesses,
and they need your help
now more than ever.
If you're watching this online,
you can hit the "donate" button.
Stay safe, wash your hands,
wear a mask, we love you.